[Applause]
good morning everyone my name is yudit
and i am somewhat of a youth activist
but really just the true enthusiast of
of peace uh democracy in europe
and uh how my relationship to these
topics changed over time is what i'm
gonna share about here today with you
and i hope many of you can connect with
it and maybe get inspired
for your own journey as well
europe day is a very special day for
many of us
my generation
i was born in 1993
has never or barely known borders on a
large part of the european continent
so we really know
what it feels like to be european and we
have convictions about what europe is
and can be if we are collaborate
some would also say that there are 447
million european citizens
um and i'm sure if you're following this
speech actually most of you are a
european citizen too
but actually that's just a number right
that's the official population of the
european union but there's so much more
uh about european democracy that we need
to uncover
not to mention that actually maybe some
people who should be considered european
citizens are missing from this number
altogether
so
these things really excite me and as a
youth activist and as a professional my
my day-to-day life in essence is
determined by building a peaceful and
democratic europe
i work now as incoming secretary general
of the young european federalists which
is a pan-european youth organization
but
my journey to get here started much
sooner of course
growing up in hungary um i had many
influences around me
i had my local and national realities of
course as a predominant one
but i understood early on that there's
something beyond these realities that is
also impacting my everyday life
for example i also had the presence of
my mom
who was born in at the time called west
germany
because my family is a german speaking
minority in hungary and they fled in
1956
when there was an uprising against the
soviets
and when that ended actually they moved
back to hungary when my mom was 10 years
old
but needless to say i already had a
sense of course of of how there's a
complexity in in our world
um
and a fun fact is that actually my name
was chosen by my mom uh so that it can
be pronounced in multiple languages
maybe this was a predetermination of
what was to come
but
essentially i was growing up in hungary
in an industrial town of 80 000 people
called tatadanya
and no one really taught me anything
about the eu or about europe
no one really taught me how to relate to
this mysterious actor called europe
but then come high school
i was lucky enough to take part in a
series of student exchanges that turned
my life completely upside down
i it opened doors i never imagined
existed
but it also made me reflect on things i
maybe simply did not want to before
but what became unavoidable was put in
contrast with others
therefore my identity brewed in many
different directions during these
teenage years
i went through a period of longing to
live in the netherlands for example
which i had the chance to visit and i
made very deep friendships there but i
also met young people from poland from
germany and also from the united states
and
i had the chance to also host them in my
own home and
because of this actually there was no
turning back for me
in realizing that we are more united
that different
while also celebrating the diversity of
our uniqueness
as
individuals
at the time however i did not think much
about it how we as a community think and
act
i simply left high school i went on to
university and i was committed to stay
part of this international life somehow
whatever that may be
and then another unexpected door opened
i took part in an eight months long
training by my local student union in
community organizing
and i felt that i found my calling
i decided to study educational sciences
because i felt what i enjoyed the most
was helping others to create the best
life for themselves and for others
around them
but little did i know you can also do
this as a volunteer um
and i learned that there and slowly i
started to deliver trainings myself and
supported other young people to to be
well equipped to participate
and on top of that i i did not expect
that actually through supporting other
people
i learned that my own voice matters too
i met wonderful mentors and peers who
cracked me open and allowed me to
express things about myself
that i cared about
and i felt empowered by my communities
to to come forward and and voice
opinions um sometimes these were
these were the ones that we all shared
and sometimes these were only my own
even if it was not the popular opinion
at the time
so from a mix of all of these
experiences a deep belief
in active youth participation emerged
and looking back it is easy to see that
actually i was learning about democracy
and europe
through practice
there i was
reborn in multiculturality and and youth
empowerment
and the natural next step was to combine
these two actually my in my actions
so during and after university i
continued to be a part of
youth and student representation and
multiple international youth
organizations
with whom we took our voices to stand up
for the ideas that we believe in
which is what i am doing to this day
and sometimes you know it happens in the
form of a thunderstorm
you take the streets for social justice
for the planet that we will live on to
be protected or to defend democracy rule
of law or human rights
but sometimes it is more in the form of
how a river is washing the shores and
creating its path in the soil you keep
on engaging with different people in
power positions over and over again
calmly and resiliently
until they take your opinions into
consideration
this is also all part of what youth
participation is
and sometimes you have to really go
again and again about the same problem
addressing the same people and see
barely any change
but sometimes
magic happens
and change does occur
so i say that ejector matters
and young people have been doing all of
it
there's a great amount of us who are
marching who are voting who are running
for elections who are also empowering
other young people to do all of these
same things
active participation in democracy has
many faces
and it can be a roller coaster believe
me
there were times when i was asked to
join certain fights or fulfill certain
positions
and i said no
i sometimes regret these decisions but
then i realized there was a reason at
the time
and i know this because there were also
other times when i took on too much and
i had to prioritize my well-being
because no one can fight for democracy
24 7.
you need to find your balance and your
purpose
at the end of the day in a democracy it
all comes down to what matters to you
and what is the best form for you to
channel it into action
through exchanging with others being
open to hear different perspectives and
respecting each other
we always find a common way forward
and it is becoming increasingly
important to understand that in our
current democracies we all have to keep
the bigger picture
in this case europe and the world
in our minds
otherwise our direct realities get
impacted as well and we have no way to
act around it
globalization and european integration
made all of us more and more dependent
on each other which brought wonderful
opportunities such as the european
solidarity corps program for example or
some other opportunities
but there is still a long way to go
there are many issues that cannot be
faced or solved alone or in fragmented
manners
pandemics do not stop at borders
the climate crisis doesn't happen in
silos
and
we all know that also the impact of war
is always a wider circle than you
anticipated
and needless to say though that human
rights are also universal
and their promotion cannot stop at
borders either
in times where racism xenophobia
homophobia or any other type of
discrimination still persists we still
have a lot to learn from each other
in times where women's rights continue
to have severe restrictions in some
countries
we still have a lot to learn from each
other
and in times where armed conflict
is back in europe
we still have a lot to learn from each
other
but the only way to peacefully do so is
through democracy
is it perfect
no of course not
but it is the best option we have
right now
to provide every european citizen with a
life of dignity
and in this fight
you
me and everyone has a part to play
fundamentally we need strong cooperation
between all actors maybe institutions or
different communities across europe
you know whether you call it federalism
as my organization jeff europe or mario
draghi would do for example
or you call it a geopolitical
eulogy and the president of the european
commission would do matters very little
at the end of the day
they all point to a type of democracy
that fosters peace
diversity and unity
something we need more of at the moment
but on the bright side uh programs like
erasmus bus or the solidarity core that
i mentioned already
are great examples for fostering
democracy in europe and beyond
they realize both the value in investing
in youth
and in learning from each other and
acting in solidarity
this is how we strengthen democracy
this is how we offer a strong way for
europe to go forward
and when this road seems a bit rocky
because some inside hate
and division instead of fostering this
learning we need to step in
and young people are often the first
ones to do so and i'm sure many of you
in this room have done that before
so therefore it's also great to see that
actually 2022 has been recognized as the
european year of youth because i feel
this is a recognition for all the work
that young people have been doing for
the present
and the future
of europe
and
to slowly close i i just hope that each
and all of you feel the strength of your
voice
today and every day
peace and democracy are not a given
they need to be fostered
europe and the world will flourish only
to our actions
and i i did not know this when i was 14.
i had this mysterious sector i didn't
understand who it was right called
europe for the european union
but by being open to new experiences and
seeking to cooperate with others i
learned
that the mysterious europe is what i
make of it
and at the end of the day each one of us
builds europe day by day so if i can do
it
you can do it too
[Applause]